I will create a new views.py file
with a route called rate/limited.
Later, I will create
a limiting decorator
to restrict the number of requests.
I should point out that for
this example, I'm using the IP address
as the identifier of the client.
This way rate limiting works even for
non-logged in users.
But you can change this for
your implementation of future projects.
Redis is an open source
in-memory data structure
that can be used as a database,
cache and message broker.
Redis provides us with a fast way to
keep track of end point requests,
that is also scalable.
Your vagrant machine already
has Redis installed.
Just run Redis server from
inside your vagrant machine
to fire up this Redis instance.
You can now point to your Redis
instance with the code here.
Now, I will make a class
called RateLimit that takes in
the new object model
introduced in Python 2.2.
I will make a variable called
expiration_window that will give my
key an extra ten seconds to expire in
redis, so that badly synchronized clocks
between workers and the redis
server do not cause any problems.
I will now create an init method for
the RateLimit class.
Taking init self the variables
key_prefix, limit, per and
send_x_headers.
Key is going to represent a string that
I will use to keep track of the rate
limits for each of the requests.
Limit and per define the number
of requests we want to allow over
a certain time period.
And send_x_headers is a Boolean option
that will allow us to inject into
each response header the number of
remaining requests a client can make
before they hit the limit.
I would define reset here
to make a timestamp to
indicate when a request
limit can reset itself.
Then I will append this to my key.
We use a pipeline to make sure that
we never increment a key without also
setting the key expiration in case an
exception happens between those lines.
For instance, if a process is killed.
I will now increment
the value of my pipeline and
set it to expire based on my reset
value and expiration window.
I'll add two lambda functions to
calculate how many remaining requests I
have left and another one that returns
true if I've hit my rate limit.
I'll define the get_view_rate_limit
function which will retrieve
the view_rate_limit from
the g-object in flask.
I will use this function later
on inside of my decorator.
I'll also make a function called
on_over_limit that returns
the message that a client has
reached their limit of requests
along with a 429 error which
means too many requests.
Now I will create a rate limit method
that will wrap around my decorator
taking in the following
values as arguments.
The key is constructed by default
from the remote address and
the current endpoint.
Before the function is executed,
it increments the rate limit,
with the help of
the rate limit class and
stores an instance on the g object,
as g._view_rate_limit.
If the view function is
indeed over the limit,
we automatically call
a different function instead.
Now, I will append the number of
remaining requests, the limit for
that end point, and
the time until the limit resets itself,
inside the header of each response,
that hits the rate limited request.
This feature can be turned off if
send_x_headers is set to false.
Whenever the rate limit
decorator is called and
speaking of ratelimit decorator I can
now add the rate limit to my route.
Here it is currently set to allow
300 requests per 30 seconds.
So if everything worked well I can
fire up my flask web app and run this
hungryclient.py file I made in order
to see how well my rate limiter works.
I will tell hungryclient to send
off 2000 requests per minute or
as fast as it can.
As you can see,
hungryclient is successfully reaching
the end point until it hits the limit.
Then it waits five seconds and
tries again.
Once the time limit is reached and
reset, more requests can be
made until we reach 2,000.
Code for this activity is
available in the instructor notes.